do you see him
do you think a depressed person could
make this
no i guess my thoughts on abortion are
you know let's just all have a good time
okay i'm just gonna double check your
form here ron
you redacted all the information i
answered some of them for date of birth
you wrote springtime which is true
everything you write down is
confidential we need you to give real
answers
fine how many drinks of alcohol do you
consume a week one that's it one drink
one shelf
do you exercise yes lovemaking and
woodworking do you have any history of
mental illness in your family i have an
uncle who does yoga allergies cowardice
and weak-willed men
and hazelnuts sexual history epic and
private okay
i'm gonna go get your doctor he's a rude
brash jerk you'll love him
tommy t you just missed the craziest of
crazies clubs girls dancing naked mom
argument police fleeing the seed hiding
in a dumpster coming here crashing on
your couch for a week cause technically
i'm homeless hey
i'm gonna hit the couch you know i'll be
this isn't a steak why would you call it
that on your menu i don't know what to
tell you man
just give me all the bacon and eggs you
have
wait wait i worry what you just heard
was give me a lot of bacon and eggs what
i said was
give me all the bacon and eggs you have
do you understand
i once forgot to brush my teeth for five
weeks i didn't actually sell my last car
i just forgot where i parked it i don't
know who al gore is and at this point
i'm too afraid to ask when they say two
percent milk i don't know what the other
98 is when i was a baby my head was so
big scientists did experiments on me i
once threw a beer at a swan and then it
attacked my niece rebecca i'm not sick i
just have allergies okay i took a
claritin and i threw that up so i took
another one i threw that up and then i
took a third and it stayed down i'm
getting better all right you're burning
up you're burning up what i have to get
out of here i have 2.8 body fat my
body's like a microchip a grain of sand
could destroy it
my body's a microchip
leslie go home no i can't i can't go
home i have to get ready for the chamber
of secrets commerce if this meeting does
not go perfectly then the harvest
festival is gonna be over before it
began i cannot go home okay then who is
your doctor
ann's my doctor
and she's the most beautiful nurse in
the world
come on
oh girl now i'm hot now it's really hot
okay well that's your fever leslie i
typed your symptoms into the thing up
here and it says you could have network
connectivity problems
so ben
why causoni glad you asked chris
you know
there's fast food hamburgers there's
fast food mexican there's fast food
chinese blah blah blah have you ever
wondered why there isn't a fast food
option for italian food what about pizza
pizza
never heard of it that's what people
will be saying in 20 years because pizza
is old news chris pizza is your
grandfather's calzone i never thought of
it that way what i'm talking about is a
portable delicious meal that is its own
container it's a whole new spin on
italian fast casual dining amazing now
you of all people like this
i'm gonna use low-fat ingredients game
changer and i will call my new italian
fast casual eatery the locale calzone
zone
that idea is literally the greatest idea
i have ever heard in my life that idea
is terrible i need a few more volunteers
andy will you be iceland the bad guys
for mighty ducks too don't think so okay
how about japan the bad guys from karate
kid too
even worse how about germany they've
never been the bad guys
[Music]
what's going on here poppy mommy is here
can we keep him my neighbor's dog had a
literally looking for people to adopt i
love him
i wish he had tiny puppy shoes
i would totally shine his little shoes
for free oh i do say the cutest stuff
look i love a good dog as much as the
next guy but this building doesn't allow
animals andy take him outside
and shoot him no just
keep him outside oh come on ron
i'm just a little puppy
i ain't done nothing wrong i'm just a
puppy
i like your mustache
i wish i could have one but i can't
cause i'm just a little bubbly
hmm
okay take him out and shoot him
[Music]
[Applause]
tom
i couldn't afford enough premium carpet
to get us to the stage i mean it was a
short walk but it was pretty luxurious
right
okay
everybody smile away
[Applause]
[Music]
still waiting on my arm andy
i'm holding the dog he is peeing he's
now peeing and putting him down
[Music]
run
run
there's no stairs
[Music]
[Music]
oh
well uh
calculator
oh you like that one huh
we do not get a lot of humor here and
when we do it's wonderful oh ted come in
here
say it to ted when he comes in
fake blood capsules
oh they didn't have any
really
that's gross i love it we are throwing a
halloween party at our house it's gonna
be the greatest thing ever someone will
die of fun and of murder there's gonna
be beer pumpkins bloody goblins fake
ones it's gonna be awesome we have
decorations dead people that we just
murdered not murdered but pictures of
dead people from tv or movies mutilated
bodies but fake ones candy dancing
tequila all kinds of food and snacks
blood orphans no blood orphans
i
i don't know what that is i'm gayle
gergich
gail your gail
jerry's beautiful wife
who
looks like that
got it got
it nice
i also got this dude's briefcase i was
just laying there kind of a panic move
i believed in you
you should put that back
you